if folks Peter Brown here at gamespot
news update confirming earlier rumors
nintendo's new 3ds will be coming out in
north america on februari 13th today's
Nintendo Direct presentation gave us
lots of new information on upcoming
games for 3ds and Wii U but we really
just wanted to know wind intendo the
next handheld was coming to the west the
new 3d s released last year in Japan and
lucky three dias ambassador members in
the UK have already gotten their hands
on the system but in the US gamers will
have to wait a few more weeks to play
with nintendo's next handheld while
japan has a smaller base version of the
new 3gs available similar to the regular
3ds North America will only have access
to XL size systems essentially they're
the same hardware but bigger however the
X all models do not support customizable
faceplates launch colors will be in
either red or black but there were also
be two special edition systems available
at launch one for majora's mask will
retail at the standard MSRP of two
hundred dollars but will not come with
the game in a monster hunter for
ultimate system that does include the
game and costs two hundred and thirty
dollars during the Nintendo Direct
presentation we also learned about a new
Fire Emblem game for 3ds a new wii u
exclusive from the director of tekken
and tons of new amoeba details speaking
for myself I'm slightly disappointed
that America is not going to get the
smaller new 3ds it's actually slightly
bigger than the regular size 3d s
already released and fills out a good
middle ground for the system of course I
want to miss out on all those sweet face
plates anyway for more nintendo news
stay tuned to gamespot com